savile a flamboyantly eccentric not  narcissistic and manipulative television  personality used his celebrity his  volunteering and fundraising roles to  gain unprecedented access to NHS  hospitals Savile status and influence in  Leeds General Infirmary Stoke Mandeville  and Broadmoor hospitals was enhanced by  the endorsement and encouragement he  received from politicians senior civil  servants and NHS managers his access  within NHS hospitals gave Savile the  opportunity to commit sexual abuses on a  grand scale for nearly 50 years Saddles  ability to avoid being caught for so  long  owed much to the social attitudes of the  time including a less intrusive media  more hierarchical and fragmented  hospital management structures and  significantly less public understanding  and acknowledgement of sexual abuse